alex with the return of face-to-face
instruction at most elementary schools
comes an increase in that school zone
traffic
yeah and safety advocates reminding
everyone to slow down please watch out
for kids as they go back to class
hector mejia live from ccsd's bus yard
in north las vegas with more on that hi
hatcher
hey there guys good morning a lot of
action going on here there you see a bus
getting ready to leave
you'll soon see you know momentarily out
in the street you'll see a lot of these
buses these yellow large school buses
taking over the streets possibly the
freeway as a lot of children
finally get back to school we're talking
about pre-k through third grade and
joining us live we have superintendent
dr jesus jarrett here to talk to us just
about how many buses are we going to see
rolling out on the streets good morning
sir
good morning good morning we have about
1600 buses that are going to be rolling
out getting our kids to school
you know it's an early start pre-k three
so we're excited to just you know with
commenting you know anticipation to get
to school on time get
ready to go it's what we've been waiting
for for so long
number one for all those parents at home
watching having breakfast getting ready
for this huge day
your main message right now be patient
with grace
and really flexibility obviously but our
buses i just want parents to understand
that we have taken every safety
precaution
recommended by the cdc and the southern
nevada health district our buses are
clean
our classrooms will be ready our
teachers are ready our principals are
ready support staff
everybody we're ready to welcome our
kids back into school
gotcha so a lot of planning has been
underway uh for those parents who
you know may still have concerns uh what
would you say to them about how the
district or what the district is doing
to make sure
that everything you know will be okay
well you know what like i said our buses
we've had them disinfected there's hand
sanitizer
i want our kids to wear their mask on
the bus i want their kids to wear the
mask in the classroom
i want you know obviously washing their
hands making sure that you do
you know practice the social distancing
and we'll be ready
our kids are going to be so excited you
know i'm hearing from our principals
that they couldn't wait to get our kids
back in the classrooms you know when you
probably look back at this day it's a
huge day what do you think we'll
you know make of this day we're talking
a lot about enforcement
safety grades well you know what the
first thing is
obviously the safety protocols make sure
that we follow all the procedures
get in the swing of things our kids have
been at home doing social distancing now
we're going to transition
this is the first of what we're going to
see in the fall we're going to see
next year it's just going to be slow
we're going to take care of the
academics
but you know what just following these
new protocols how we're going to live
in our schools and our classrooms follow
directions and we'll be okay
get them in get them fed and get them
home as you see this going on
live right behind you what do you make
of this what's on your mind
it's exciting you know it's kind of what
i've been looking for for so long
you know hearing the buses going uh
seeing the kids it's going to be a great
day it's going to be
so exciting for our educators this is
the way that we're supposed to be in our
schools in our classroom
in front of our kids and this is just an
exciting day for me
i couldn't sleep last night you know
just being ready to get here
to see what we're supposed to be doing
in front of our students so we have more
students returning back to campus
back to campus different grade levels in
the coming weeks how confident are you
in the district's plan well you know
what i mean right now the full companies
have a great team
our principals our staff they've been
ready to go
this is you know i'm very confident that
we're going to be you know this is going
to be
the first step in getting them to face
to face in the fall and continuing this
rejection for us
superintendent thank you very much for
your time we appreciate talking with you
thank you so uh the superintendent is
moving on to uh different schools we'll
have
coverage on this back to school day huge
day throughout the day for now reporting
live hector mejia
8 news now back to you thank you very
much good to see the bus engines are
working in
primo condition despite the fact they
haven't been used a whole lot in the
last few months so
hector thank you and thank you to dr
jarrah as well